thing so you really think that the metoo
movement has contributed to male sexless
sexlessness yes they don't want the rest
yeah because I because I have access to
like thousands of clients and I hear
these these things all the time and you
know the guys in Australia
a lot of them couldn't even leave
because of the you know during the
pandemic but they're really terrified
about getting in a situation where a
girl later says hey I changed my mind
about consent and then what happens from
there right or or a guy you know
approaching a girl and she doesn't like
it maybe in the UK is he now going to
get in trouble right so
as we said not many people were called
approaching to begin with but when you
put these kind of restrictions on guys
are even more intimidated right because
now there's not just rejection there's
also legal consequences has that ever
happened to any of your clients or
someone you know
um getting in trouble for for no I can't
think of any any instances but I think
it's more of uh it just makes people gun
shy yeah it's more that it could happen
yeah